arkansas governor asa hussion hutchinson
a republican came out this week
and admitted oops i shouldn't have
signed a
ban on masked mandates in my state
now that coveted numbers are going
through the roof again
i messed up is the message that we got
from
arkansas republican governor asa
hutchinson
this week here's a couple quotes i want
to read here this is what hutchinson
said well i signed it at the time
because our cases
were at a very low point i i knew it'd
be overridden by the legislature if i
didn't sign it i already eliminated our
statewide mass
mandate i signed it for those reasons
that our cases were at a low point
everything has changed now
and yes in hindsight i i wish that had
not
become law
so yeah i did it
oops wish i hadn't but you know
it's not like i'm in a position of power
to do anything about it
you are though okay and hey it's great
that you've come around and realized you
messed up
too little possibly too late at this
point he is of course
now asking the legislature to at least
overturn the part of the law that
doesn't allow school districts
to decide whether to put mass mandates
in place so at the very least asa
hutchinson is
is out there begging the
republican-controlled legislature
can you guys at least make it to where
school districts get to make their own
decisions about protecting the kids
but folks this is what happens this is
why you can't have these reactionaries
as leaders they give in
to the worst of their constituents
the people who say that masks are
tyranny or that masks are somehow
oppression
they're neither by the way
but they signed this law to gain
political points
both over in arkansas over here in
florida
because they think it's going to gain
them some political points
and then boom everything blows up
and their hands are essentially tied at
this point now
over here in florida ron desantis could
could come out and make the same kind of
statements that asa hutchinson has
because at least hutchinson had the good
sense to be like whoa
folks i messed up so bad
of course he wasn't that extreme with it
but desantis is over here
watching again as we just had a day
where 20 000 people
got diagnosed with covid i have family
members in the hospital right
now down in south florida in the icu
so this is a personal thing for me it is
a political thing for me it does hit
close to home for me
and desantis is doubling down saying
yeah biden i'm going to stand in your
way
i am not going to comply i am not going
to listen to the cdc
i am not going to let anyone other than
me
decide what's best for the millions and
millions of residents here in the state
of florida that oh
by the way are dropping dead
because of my idiotic decisions
desantis's poll numbers have also taken
a massive hit
because of this as i mentioned the one
poll obviously he's
trailing his democratic rival that one
will change
hopefully for the better but his
approval rating has now fallen to 43
as of this morning now
43 percent still not horrible
but when you consider the support that
this guy had he has dropped by double
digits
in just the last month
that's how extreme this is that's how
extreme he
is and the residents are waking up to it
and they're waking up to it
every time another relative goes into
the hospital
they're waking up to it every time they
have to put another family member in the
ground
it's terrifying and it's horrible that
this is what it's taking some people to
finally wake up and realize that
sometimes you have to put the science
over the politics
but people are starting to see exactly
how dangerous desantis's policies
truly are he's not going to pull an asa
hutchinson
he's not going to come out and say i
screwed up i regret this
he's going to continue to double down
because he thinks
it's going to help him politically even
though the numbers show
it's doing the exact opposite i'm fair
and cousin sitting in for
uh david pakman today we'll be right
back
if you ever feel like you just don't
have enough time to read all the books
you want to read
you have to check out one of my favorite
apps called blinkist blinkist takes
thousands of popular nonfiction books
and distills each one down into an ebook
or audiobook
that you can get through in just 15
minutes where you're getting all the key
takeaways from the book
just imagine how you'll be able to
expand your horizons and knowledge
by being able to soak up all of the
important insights from
10 different books in an afternoon
obviously it's perfect for exposing
yourself to a new book
you otherwise wouldn't have time for or
you can use it to revisit a book you've
already read
or use it to preview a book before you
buy the full version and read it
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription
is only about eight bucks a month and
you get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get twenty five percent off a
subscription when you go to blinkist.com
pacman i've put the link right
underneath this video